christian lindner muss sich
entschuldigen bei ex fdp generalsekretär
in linda teuteberg der grund sein zotige
spruch über ihre zusammenarbeit
ich denke gerne daran dass wir in den
vergangenen 15 monaten ungefähr 300 mal
den tag zusammen begonnen haben
ich spreche über unser tägliches
morgendliches telefonat nicht was ihr
jetzt denkt oder friedrich merz auch er
steht in der kritik nach dieser aussage
über homosexuelle hätten sie vorbehalte
wenn heute ein schwuler bundeskanzler
würde solange sich das im rahmen der
gesetze bewegt und so lange es nicht
kinder betrifft beide politiker sind
wiederholungstäter lindner brachte seine
zweite schon einmal ich bin heute morgen
wach geworden mit claudia roth ich habe
gesagt mit nicht nehmen und märz
antwortete seinerzeit auf die frage wie
er fände das berlin vom schwulen spd
politiker klaus wowereit regiert wird
solange er sich mir nicht nähert ist mir
das egal
was ist da los direkt weiter was ist da
los
also ich glaube man muss vor allem
unterscheiden weil wir haben mit zwei
verschiedenen fällen zu tun bei dem 1
der vorwurf des sexismus im raum und bei
der mehrheit geht es sozusagen um
homophoben ansatz und ich muss sagen
dass ich finde dass er sich mit dieser
aussage auch das qualifiziert hat als
kandidat für mich ist das sozusagen ein
gestriges verhalten und ein ansatz wenn
man über das thema homosexualität
spricht und im selben atemzug sozusagen
pädophile damit assoziiert dann ist das
nicht das problem des jähnigen den er
meint sondern derjenige der das
sozusagen ausspricht und ich glaube
deutlich wird es daran das ist natürlich
so ist das wenn auch heterosexuelle
einvernehmlich sozusagen miteinander in
austausch gehen dass das auch den
gesetzen entsprechen muss man aber nie
auf die idee kommen würde in dem fall zu
sagen aber aber beim thema pädophile und
und kinder und so weiter müssen wir
eingrenzen und ich finde das hat das
beispiel ganz deutlich gezeigt dass
konservativ nicht gleich konservativ ist
denn denjenigen der dort anspricht das
ist ja jens spahn der für den modernen
konservativismus steht und ich finde das
ist das bild ist ewiggestrigen und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe lieber
einen homosexuellen kanzler als einen
homophoben ja also das finde ich auch
muss man ganz klar unterscheiden
und ich sehe das auch kritisch was
friedrich merz war von sich gegeben hat
dass das ist wirklich das geht das geht
einfach nicht mehr das also nicht mehr
dass das war lang genug leider so und
das muss jetzt dann das damit ist das
ganz schwierig kanzler zu werden zu
wollen finde ich auch das einfach
schwierig und bei herrn lindner muss ich
ehrlich gesagt dank das kalt dass das
bei mir eher so was
das ist so eine so eine koketterie eines
möchtegern junggebliebenen
das ist schon irgendwie so eine show wie
junggesellen gehabe das kann ich nicht
wirklich ernst nehmen und ich glaube
auch die frauen die er da sozusagen mit
denen er da vermeintlich jeden morgen
telefoniert hat oder mit denen er jetzt
aufgewacht ist über längeren zeitraum
ich glaube die sind so gestanden
die hmi können das auch nicht ernst
nehmen ich glaube die shop einfach
nichts mehr weil man ihm gewohnt sind
ich glaube das ist also ich glaube dass
er eine andere klasse also ich glaube
dass frau gut sich darüber über diesen
satz glaube ich glaube wir sollten wir
es richtig aufregen über reids ich muss
halt kurz unterbrechen das rege mich so
wahnsinnig auf mit welchen ganze und es
ist keine lappalie das möchte ich mal
ganz glänzende märz über lindner bei
merz habe ich wiederum nahm aber jetzt
gerade über den winter zu kommen
es ist überhaupt keine lappalie ist er
sieht aus wie ein 12-jähriger und macht
herrenwitze wie ein 70-jähriger und das
ist bei ihm ein system das spricht für
eine art er kann nicht anders von man
und das spricht auch dafür dass er die
art und weise wie er frauen sieht wenn
er immer wieder sich die lacher solche
altherren schenkelklopfer auf die seite
sieht damit zu generieren wenn von einem
parteitag das einzige ist was übrig
bleibt ein altherren willst bei einer
partei die umfrage mäßig im keller ist
dann muss man sich wirklich die frage
stellen ob dieser mann an der spitze
dieser park 1 raum das sollte ich glaube
genau da sollte das sollte genau die
konsequenzen sollte sich die partei
genau überlegen wen sie da eigentlich
nach wie vor seit jahren immer noch an
die spitze lässt und so fernsehen ist
also das ist genau das aber ist keine
lappalie da ist es nicht so ein naja das
ist halt einmal anspruch bewerber das
sogar eines tages qualifizierung
seinerseits die die spricht für sich
also finde wenn jemand das jetzt
wiederholt irgendwie also so was da von
sich gibt mal auf dem podium ob das eine
sah aus wie irgendwie so eine
wahlkampfveranstaltung irgendwie er so
offen auf dem land oder irgendwie um ihr
held genauso wie er das daneben macht
vor sag mal vor laufenden kameras
irgendwie auf einer größeren breiteren
öffentlichkeit dann ist damit irgendwie
alles gesagt da kann ich würde ich sagen
als aber disqualifiziert sich an den
moment auch selbst und ich glaube wir
sind jetzt ein minister muss doch weiter
als über sowas
ich weiß waren erlebten heimgesetz der
vorteil ist dass wir in einem
gesellschaftlichen klima mittlerweile
leben wo das geächtet wird das war
jahrzehntelang nicht der fall das ist
übrigens der unterschied das heißt das
ist ja auch der grund warum das so
aufgefallen ist weil man das jetzt
konfrontiert im übrigen nicht von den
heute selber das finde ich auch nochmal
ganz bemerkenswert sondern das haben
andere frauen gemacht sozusagen auch aus
solidaritäts gründen und die tatsache
dieses beispiel aufzuwerfen das wäre
einem mann nicht passiert das wäre
vielleicht einer älteren frau auch nicht
passiert und natürlich wenn man damit
auch assoziationen auslösen
und ich halte das schon auch für ein
kunstgriff sozusagen also ein stil
ansatz also auch mit dieser kurzen pause
zwischendurch und daneben die lacher
abwarten die reaktion und ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig ist zu erkennen dass
das immer noch sehr häufig funktioniert
ich möchte ganz kurz amazon märz zurück
zu kommen sie jetzt auf ihn zurück weil
ich habe das ganz ehrlich und jetzt
krieg ich wahrscheinlich von euch dreien
gleichen sich kritisch werden alle
klatschen ich habe es ganz anders
gesehen wie denn ich habe mir dieses
interview ganz oft angeschaut und ich
das war für mich ganz klar
patricia einstellung auf die schultern
für mich war das areal vorbehalte denn
ein schwuler bundeskanzler werden würde
nein punkt dann wurde noch mal nach der
fahrt zu will ich endlich auch mal doch
doch dort war eine frage
nein nein nein dann hat er gesagt für
sie völlig normal sagt der journalist
daraufhin sagt ja ich hab's mir sogar
abgeschrieben ich sag mal so die frage
der sexuellen orientierung das geht die
öffentlichkeit nichts an so lange es
nicht mit pädophilie und so weiter zu
tun und so
meiner meinung nach hat das überhaupt
nichts mit homosexualität zu tun sondern
erklärt sein satz weil er in dem moment
wurde den satz sagt ich sag mal so die
frage der sexuellen orientierung das
gedacht lichkeit nichts anhat er gerd um
ist das muss ich noch mal erklärt muss
krieg richtig eine backpfeife also ich
meine solange es ihm im rahmen des
gesetzes bleibt ich glaube damals lerner
an dem ist was sag ich glaube dass er
eigentlich nur was sexuelle sexuelle
freiheit und auch erklären muss ja aber
danach müssen wir ganz verleugnen
beispiel schwimmen muss jetzt mal rein
wir erklären euch das beispiel wowereit
beispiel volare wowereit hat er sich ja
auch ähnlich gross hat nach dem motto
der kann auch gerne spur sein solange er
mich dabei nicht langfristig so jetzt
hab ich herr meister zwar schnee angriff
seien ungefähr so exotisch ist wirklich
vom vorherigen jahrhundert absolut ist
ich bin doch kein so haben etwa
versuchen
für ihn ist das in seinem in seiner
kleinen welt die für mich wieso ja wie
so eine kleine spießige professoren welt
abläuft ist es für ihn etwas ganz
exotisches wo er auch erstmal so ja weiß
ich jetzt nicht kann ich jetzt ich würde
das passt natürlich überhaupt nicht in
unsere zeit weiß ich aber nicht finde
ist dass man ihm unterstellt homophob zu
sein ich glaube es jedes mal ganz
ehrlich ich aber natürlich müssen wir
das passende ich richtung mal erwähnte
er cdu erfordert wird irgendwann kanzler
wird dann müssen wir sehr wohl die frage
stellen die düsen gerade aufgeworfen hat
ne ist kann der in der vorbildfunktion
eigentlich also was heißt eigentlich
friedrich merz einen ein hoch
intelligenter hoch gebildet war
unglaublich gut rhetorisch ausgewählt
verrät nach der der es auch liebt mit
worten sozusagen antworten zu feilen und
mit worten dinge also komplizierte dinge
darzustellen und ebenda erstaunlich
unbeholfen irgendwie dann aber auch da
aber auch das gar nicht wirklich so
irgendwie gemeint hat aber dann selber
gemerkt das läuft jetzt irgendwie verbal
in die falsche richtung
aber da erwarte ich dann tatsächlich von
einem mann wie ihm dass er sich vorher
ein bisschen besser sortiert und das
dann auch in der rhetorik zur über
bekommt dass es eben nicht so ankommt
wie es angekommen ist grundsätzlich
dennoch auch hier dieses jedes wort auf
die goldwaage zu legen
von von politikern oder menschen die auf
sich um in dem fall geben auch weitere
ehrgeizige politische ambitionen
verfolgen finde ich ein bisschen mehr
wenn es mal ein bisschen mehr
gemeinsamkeit auch ganz gut erst
sortieren oder erst nachdenken noch viel
besser dann sortieren und dann sprechen
[Musik]